[Music]
foreign
monster from the upcoming Netflix movie
of the same name as big as monster verse
gong so here in this video we will
assess the origins size biology and
powers of that Troll and compare it to
Kong from the 2017 monster verse movie
Skull Island
let's start with the description this
troll first of all seems to have very
human-like face with two eyes a broad
nose and a mouth full of deadly teeth as
well as two pairs of long canines that
jot out from the top and lower jaw this
troll has a very prominent Viking beard
that is surprisingly made up of what
looks to be Roots branches and grass the
screen of the troll is filled with Rocky
osteaderms and outgrowths that fit
perfectly with the terrain of the region
a sort of camouflage for the icy and
desolate region of Norway this monster
has two arms and two legs but instead of
having five digits like us humans it has
four fingers and four toes on each hand
and foot
now let's take a look at its origins The
Troll initially thought to be a myth a
fairy story was indeed a real life
monster in that universe that somehow
hibernated in a deep Cavern and was
awoken by human exploration or by ground
excavation the trolls were in fact
humanoid beings that exist as a tribal
group and we know this by looking at one
of the scenes whereby we see a bunch of
gigantic humanoid skeletons in a cave
together even baby skeletons this shows
that these monsters were present
alongside humans of the Nordic region
for as far as time can tell this troll
seems to be the last surviving member
and is hellbent on killing humans as he
blames them for the death of his own
species
now the biology of the troll is somewhat
a bit complicated we can see from the
skeletons in the cave that he is in fact
a primate a gigantic humanoid that has a
skeleton that is almost exactly like
ours although the Hat seems to be more
Bubbles at the top and the jaw looks to
be more like an extinct subspecies of
human or even monkey-like it is not a
magical being but a blood and bones
creature as all else although on a
gigantic level and probably has a
carnivorous diet the skin of the troll
is the most interesting part it has a
thick epidermis of outer skin layer that
possesses a rocky outer layer for
camouflage as well as defense it's hair
and beard are made up of branchy and
root outroads which makes him kind of
like a floral formal specimen like the
scare buffaloes of Skull Island 2017.
now let's take a look at his size this
is our area of expertise by looking at
the Beats he seems to be somewhat in the
same size range as King Kong from 2017.
let's first take a look at the footprint
in the mud in a scene directly inspired
by the Godzilla scene of 1998 a
scientist again is inside the footprint
of a gigantic monster and the size of
this a footprint is around 30 feet from
Heel To Toe another scene that was
inspired by a Kaiju movie another Kaiju
movie we see the troll being surrounded
by helicopters just like Kong was in Sky
Island this definitely puts him in the
same size range as Kong but on another
scene we see him walking by buildings
and we see a two-story house that is
probably around 9 meters or 30 feet
which is kind of standard and we see its
height it's only at his knees and from
that we can actually extrapolate his
actual height to be around 120 feet or
37 meters
so what are the powers the sole power of
the creature is his gigantic size being
around 120 feet tall has its upsides as
you can deal a lot of damage to
buildings military equipment and
everything else as a whole He seems to
be a bit sluggish though and doesn't
seem to move as fast as a human with the
same body proportions but that weakness
is somehow made up for by his super
durable and tough outer skin
as we can see in the trailer he can
withstand missile strikes tank shells
heavy bullets and bombs although he
could be heard he can still withstand a
lot more damage than many monsters of
the same caliber another power of His is
the ability to hibernate and effectually
hide from sensors for hundreds of years
plummeting his metabolism to a
death-like state or an unliving slumber
so let's compare him to Khan from 2017
but first let's describe com here's a
gentle and peaceful ape super species
from the hollow Earth that came to live
in a remote island called Skull Island
he is a sympathetic almost human-like
figure but when provoked he becomes
Fierce and brutal as skull Island's
Guardian he protects his wildlife and
even befriends some of the invading
humans he is the loss of his species
having lost his family to skull crawlers
when he was young gone from that movie
is around 104 feet tall or 31.6 meters
tall and weighs around 158 tons however
when we see him again in Godzilla vs
Kong he would have tripled in size to
337 feet in height or 102 meters
so comparing the two gone would be a bit
shorter than the troll Kong who is 104
feet tall and a troll who is 120 feet in
height Kong would also be less durable
than this monster since we have seen
Kong being hurt by bullets while this
Beast can withstand missiles and tank
shells the one advantage that Kong has
is his agility and speed he can run
faster and jump from one place to
another outmaneuvering the rocky Stoney
monster
so power wise the troll has the upper
hand while with Speed and Agility com
holds the top spot
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam